no matter what the packers did last
night they couldn't avoid the onslaught
of the 49ers damn it i knew this was
going to happen
but here's the thing yeah we see the
49ers struggle with the cardinals right
lose to the seahawks yeah struggle with
the cardinals right i thought maybe they
had peaked too soon they peaked last
night they stuck it yes to the green bay
packers who should never play another
game in california ever again right well
you know for the second time in
california they played the same
defensive scheme right the chargers
played the same thing the 49ers do
except the 49ers are more talented you
know i think i took the 49ers three-game
stretch of that little low first off of
one of the all-time showings by a great
defensive player in judean county and a
great game just by the seahawks in
general and you're right they stumbled a
little against the cardinals but hey we
can't forget great teams always go
through a little period of like not so
great football i mean even the greatest
of all time i mean you can go back we
can go back to a number of teams and
look at it so i just think they hit a
little lull and of course they were
playing a team i think in kyla murray
and company who were a good matchup but
nonetheless
they were dominant last night and i just
think to me the my first thing would be
hey the packers are good but they're not
ready for big boy football they're
really not i don't think they're in the
class of them the same you know i mean
them as in the 49ers the saints right uh
who else am i missing there i'm missing
another team there uh seattle and
seattle those three i don't i think they
separate themselves in the nfc i just
think they're so big and physical up
front and that's really an issue for the
green bay packers as you saw last night
i mean they were steamrolled on both
sides of the ball their defense actually
played about as good as we've seen this
year
but regardless they couldn't protect
rogers they couldn't run the ball and
the 49ers seem to be back rolling the
way they were a few weeks ago and it was
one of those nights where jimmy
garoppolo did not have to do much he
threw 20 passes completed 14 253 yards
145.8 passer rating but he didn't have
to make a clutch play it was a
suffocation from the outside it was it
can't be a suffocation for
three postseason games at some point
he's gonna have to make a play in the
playoffs it's not gonna be as easy as it
was last night george kittle coming back
from missing two games with knee and
ankle injury six catches 129 yards and a
touchdown it was the third highest
perceiving output for a game in his
career but the packers just got shut
down they only scored eight points 2.83
yards per play one of 15 on third down
aaron rodgers had 104 yards for the
entire game it just was not good enough
by the green bay packers it wasn't even
close to being good no well first thing
i want to hit on your point with the
49ers again he had 14 completions for
253 yards though and you know a lot of
that is shanahan there's no doubt i mean
it's a great play design on the george
kittle post right the little corner post
off the bootleg very creative so you
know him being back healthy you know
shows what they're capable of in the
past game you know we see another
well-designed pass play for uh debo
samuel on a drop back pass right he hits
him in stride he can make a play goes up
the sideline so they're very talented
and i think when they're completely
healthy on the offensive side of the
ball especially and really once they get
joe staley back you know i don't know if
they're ever going to really have to
depend on jimmy garoppolo the way we
think they might to where it's never
just going to be totally on him um but
do you know but at some point it is on
him yeah i get it he's going to have to
make a play okay well like that game two
weeks ago on a monday night if he makes
a throw here or there last drive they
get in the field goal range and they win
instead of the seahawks and they're
undefeated i get you but he made some
throws in that game too he can't forget
they dropped you know dropped the third
down throw that was going into score i
mean they might score right there but
instead they have to kick a field goal
to make it 21 all he did do some good
things in that game too
but
back to your point your second point
with the packers that is real i mean i
think the one thing we can't get fooled
with the packers is how many games
they've kind of won and didn't look that
great right to me that's one of the
things i mean the carolina game we can
go back and look that and i would go if
we if we said who won the majority of
the plays of that game i would go
carolina probably did we know the
chargers beat them the chiefs outplayed
them as you've heard me say a million
times aaron rodgers has made some plays
in that game because their defense isn't
talented enough to really suffocate him
that that won the game for them the
raiders they never stopped the raiders
that day remember josh jacobs fumbled on
the one yard line derek carr fumbled on
the one yard line so there's been
concerning moments the detroit lion game
on on what was that a monday night
monday flowers right again so
you know they
i don't want to say they're they're
fraudulent fraudulent i can't say that
word today yeah i know it's the second
time once it was off air and i said it's
fraudulent i know you still go
throttling and it's in my brain when in
doubt pick a different world okay well
counterfeit so i think they're tony
they're good i just don't gain the cream
of the crop to me the cream of the crop
in the nfl right now is the 49ers the
seahawks the saints the ravens the
patriots i think those five stand alone
and then there's a lot of teams you know
nipping at their heels and trying to get
into that
conversation here's matt lafleur coach
of the green bay packers in his ugliest
loss during his first season with the
team very simple message for the packers
after the game
we got out coached and we got outplayed
and we've got a
man up we got to look at ourselves
critically um
and get a lot of stuff corrected we got
to be honest with herself uh but uh
you know it just it wasn't it wasn't
nearly good enough
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports